les autorités locales de la ville de
massoud t ont décidé de ne prendre aucun
risque
le confinement du village a donc été
imposée la route principale est
aujourd'hui fermé il est aussi interdit
d'accéder aux plages le but tenter
d'éviter la propagation du cosby 19 et
d'engorger les hôpitaux de la région
dans le cas d'une contamination de masse
rares sont les patients qui pourraient
avoir accès aux soins
c'est pourquoi la communauté s'organise
précisément pour faire face parce que la
seule chose que nous avons maintenant
pour éviter une contagion massive c'est
ça que toutes les personnes de notre
communauté reste à la maison
ça n'a pas été facile beaucoup de
personnes sont mécontentes ou l'était au
début mais au fur et à mesure que la
maladie progresse et que l'on sait
comment elle évolue sur notre territoire
les gens prennent conscience et
rejoignent de plus en plus notre cause
un confinement de la population que le
gouvernement mexicain refuse toujours de
mettre en place à l'échelle nationale à
massoud t7 lute contre le gros navires
us place ses habitants sous tension
comme un ramiro garcia dont les revenus
provenaient uniquement de son activité
de guide touristique
ce qu'il se passe en ce moment toute
cette controverse autour du colis 19 ça
nous affecte vraiment beaucoup et
surtout moi qui me suis spécialisé dans
le tourisme tout ce qui se passe par ici
c'est vraiment fou on est en train de
lutter pour notre survie en 2020 ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai hâte
que tout cela se termine que nous
puissions reprendre nos activités
malgré les restrictions imposées cette
station balnéaire semble rester un
endroit idyllique pour les touristes
alors que la pandémie continue de
paralyser la moitié de la population
mondiale
au départ je suis venu à mexico pour
réaliser un reportage
ensuite je me suis rendu amazon t pour
faire une sorte de pause et travailler
sur moi même du kung fu des cours de
saxophone
puis le coronavirus est arrivé ça m'a
inspiré et j'ai commencé à réaliser une
série documentaire sur ce sujet cela
s'appellera quarantaine au paradis
massoud tu es un coin de paradis à
l'arrêt donc dans un pays où la pandémie
devrait atteindre son pic le mois
prochain